عبرت القوات الاسرائيليه الشريط الذي كانت
وضعته كعلامه الحدود وحاولت تجريف هذه
المنطقه واقامه خندق بطول كيلومترات ربما
لاجراءات تقول الامم المتحده انها اجراءات
امنيه بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش
اللبناني استنفر في مقابل القوات
الاسرائيليه وقامت قوات الامم المتحده
وفقا لمهامها بالفصل بين الطرفين وثم قام
عدد من المواطنين اللبنانيين بتجمهور في
هذا المكان وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه
باطلاق القنابل المسيله للدموع وايضا
باطلاق
القذائف الصوتيه باتجاههم قامت بتعزيزات
الى هذه المنطقه تشاهدون هذه الدبابه على
راس هذه الطلبه وطبعا هي جزء من دبابات
انتشرت على طول هذه المنطقه كما انتشر
جنود خلف الصخور وخلف الشجيرات التي تغطي
هذه المنطقه من خلال كفر شوبا
عمليا يعتبر هذه المنطقه منطقه لبنانيه
خالصه وايضا منطقه ليست خاضعه للقرار 425
وبالتالي هو يطالب بكامل هذه الاراضي من
تلال باتجاه منطقه الجولان المحتل وهي
اراضي لبنانيه وايضا منطقه مزارع شبعه
الامم المتحده لا تريد من اي نزاح حدودي
او قادم للحدود من ان يؤدي الى تصعيد
الموقف قوات الامم المتحده تطلب منا الان
مغادره هذه المنطقه باعتبارها خطيره
بالنسبه اليهم وهي تريد تبريد الموقف بشكل
كامل حتى تتمكن من بدء اتصالات بين
الطرفين في محاوله لنزع فتيل هذا الموقف
المستجد في منطقه فرشوبه والذي يتكرر في
عدد من المناطق الحدوديه في جنوب لبنان
ايهاب العقده فرشوبه جنوب لبنان